foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is good for at least one post a day over
at profootballtalk.com actually a lot
more than that and I wanted to bring on
Mike specifically because I know we're
going to talk about Aaron Rodgers and I
know we're gonna have Marcellus Wiley on
later to talk about what the Packers
should do with Aaron Rodgers very
important when you're talking about the
NFL you have to understand the money you
have to understand what the players
options are what the team's options are
and Mike Florio does a terrific job
profootballtalk.com at pro football talk
had a breakdown of exactly why it's not
really in the Packers hands at this
point is that right Mike
well look the Packers and Hello Ross
good to talk to you it's been a while
the Packers worried for two years about
Aaron Rodgers wanting to leave at some
level they may be worrying about Aaron
Rodgers wanting to stay at a time when
they may be ready for him to go and
they've tied their hands with the
contract they gave him earlier this year
he's due nearly 60 million next year
fully guaranteed
they cut him he still gets the money now
it would be subject to offset if he goes
somewhere else but no one's going to pay
him 60 million next year they got a huge
problem they got a cap issue they'd have
to deal with even if they trade him the
cap hit would be crippling so unless he
decides to retire
and walks away from that 60 million and
he set up a contract so he could without
Financial consequence having to pay back
money for example he can walk away
if he walks away
problem solved they moved on to Jordan
love but if he stays he's getting that
60 million and what are they going to do
put him on the bench and pay him 60
million dollars so if they're thinking
now maybe the time to Pivot to Jordan
love and he looked pretty good the other
night against the Eagles
Aaron Rodgers is going to have a big say
in whether that happens and that's a
wrinkle that the Packers haven't been
dealing with they've been so worried
about him leaving now they have to worry
about him wanting to stay when they may
want him to go somewhere else or retire
so because I I had heard that it was
basically uh a one-year deal and then
sort of we'll see after that in terms of
what happens but it sounds like that's
only from the Roger's perspective and
his ability to get out of it move on not
really from the Packers perspective I'm
a little surprised Mike that they
seemingly didn't consider this
possibility that he might play poorly or
that they might want to move on to
Jordan love especially since next year
will be year four for Jordan love like
they might they totally kind of gave up
on Jordan love
well I don't think it's that I just
think that they assumed after they saw
Aaron Rodgers win back-to-back MVPs
after they used a first round pick and a
fourth round pick to get Jordan love
because they used the four to trade up
to get him
I don't think they expected Aaron
Rodgers to fall off the way that he has
this year or the team to fall off the
way that it has and
with this thumb injury rib injury Aaron
Rodgers openly saying he wants to play
until they're mathematically eliminated
I think is a practical matter they may
be at the point where it's done we see
Jordan Love play really well on Sunday
night you're at the point if you're the
Packers I mean if I was a Packers fan
I'd say I want to see Jordan love the
rest of the way give him some reps get
him ready for next year let's see what
we have they got to make a decision on
his fifth year option by May of 2023.
they don't have enough data to come to a
good decision as to what to do about
Jordan love for next year and Beyond so
I would be very antsy about wanting to
see what we have with Jordan love so we
know whether or not we've got a
successor in the building to Aaron
Rodgers at a time when it feels like
Aaron Rodgers is starting to decline and
from his perspective he holds all the
cards he can do whatever he wants to do
and even if he's inclined to retire now
he'd have to be inclined to walk away
from that 60 million but he may decide
to just stick around just to throw a
little wrench into the front office's
plan I mean we've seen that kind of
impishness from Aaron Rodgers elsewhere
so I think it's a delicate situation if
the Packers are thinking hey we'd like
to move on the worst thing they could do
is let Aaron Rodgers know that that's
what they're thinking
talk with Mike Florio here on The Dan
Patrick Show from pro football talk
Polly remind me to look up impishness
during the break well to make sure I
fully understand I think I got it come
on you went to Princeton don't play
don't act like the big dumb rock head
you went to hey hey Mike you know I
forgot that it was cojones instead of
cajon's I said kajjones for the uh for
the nutshot heard round the world by
Christian pulisic yesterday I'm glad by
the way Mike you mentioned Roger's
comments I feel like I'm the only person
that that really bothered that he came
out and publicly said as long as we're
still in it and we're not eliminated I
want to play which might correct me if
I'm wrong here
that Intimates that if they are
eliminated that he doesn't want to play
well hold on a second you're making a
ton of money dude and not only that do
you think David bhaktiari who's had
three surgeries on that knee and it's
going to have an arthritic knee the rest
of his life you think he wants to play
out the string you think Mercedes Lewis
Mike in year 17 at 38 years old wants to
play four or five meaningless games at
tight end I feel like I'm the only one
that noticed those comments by Rogers or
took in the task on that well and it
didn't surprise me because Ross I've
thought all along that the moment they
were done that's when he's going to
slide the injured reserve because of the
thumb injury that we didn't know was
broken until after he looked horrible in
the fourth quarter against the Tennessee
Titans missing Sammy Watkins when he was
wide open on a drive when they could
have cut it to a one score game missing
Alan Lazard horribly over the top
getting booed by the home fans then all
of a sudden we hear that it's a broken
thumb and then we hear it's an evulsion
fracture where the bone and the ligament
are tastic it's amazing he's still
playing all this stuff that was the same
injury for the past two months and he
looked pretty damn good against the
Cowboys four days before he didn't look
good against the Titans so it felt to me
like it was moving toward
sliding to injured reserve at the right
time and the the other thing too I don't
know mathematically eliminated and done
are two different things they may not be
mathematically eliminated for a while
but it kind of feels like they're done
and I feel like if they lose to the
Bears this week
and they go to their buy I don't think
he plays on the other end of it because
of that thumb injury and because they
will as a practical matter be done if
they don't beat the Bears they should be
able to beat the Bears though especially
if they don't have Justin Fields but if
they if they lose in Chicago then they
are done then why not see what Jordan
love can do get the guy some reps and
figure out what his ceiling may be
I am now totally fascinated by the idea
Mike of Jordan love comes in the last
four games plays awesome looks great
Packers fans are excited and Roger says
the team yeah no I'm staying I'm staying
I'm not retiring
um you can trade me if you want but no I
mean he has the chance to totally
reverse the script of him being mad for
them screwing him over by drafting
Jordan love he could go if he chooses he
can stick it to them to end this thing
and a lot of guys wouldn't want to do
that he strikes me as a guy that
wouldn't mind sticking it to them on the
way out well Ross for so much of his
career he was a guy who stayed away from
any type of controversy he was very
sensitive about being disliked by anyone
and he's taken that heel turn over the
past couple of years where he kind of
likes it I think he kind of digs knowing
that there's going to be some people who
are behind him and some people who hate
him and he he's he's cool with that and
what better way to be and he wears black
all the time what he is with all the
black I think he kind of likes this this
bad guy image it's the ultimate bad guy
to say to the Packers sucks for you you
owe me 60 million dollars if you want to
put me on the bench that's fine but I
want my money if you want to cut me
that's fine but I want my money if you
want to trade me good luck to your
salary cap and then you have to deal
with me as the quarterback for whoever
you trade me to
curious to get your thoughts Mike on
Jeff Saturday Monday night didn't call
the time out yesterday comes out and
says he made a mistake what I thought
was interesting and you and I look at
some things the same way
there were a lot of people especially
insiders Mike that couldn't wait to
pounce on a coaching error or a
perceived error by Saturday I give him
credit for taking accountability and
saying yeah learning experience but man
people were salivating they were waiting
for that moment to say see he screwed up
he shouldn't be the coach
I think we I think I think Mike just
froze on us on the zoom there either
that or my question was that good anyway
appreciate having Mike on the show Mike
thank you very much check him out at pro
football talk Mike obviously does a
terrific job